Alabama Senate candidate Roy Moore
denies the newest claim of sexual
misconduct against him but this morning
more Republicans are calling on the
former judge to drop out of the race
a fifth accuser named Beverly young
Nelson says Moore tried to force her
into sex when she was just 16 years old
she told her story in an emotional news
conference yesterday the incident
happened about 40 years ago now the
National Republican Senatorial Committee
called more unfit to serve and said if
he is elected to the Senate he should
then be expelled Manuel Bojorquez is in
Birmingham Alabama the state Republican
Party headquarters man well good morning
good morning the state GOP is cautiously
waiting this out but Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell has joined a long
list of Senate Republicans saying that
Moore should step down Moore fired back
on Twitter saying McConnell should step
aside Moore is doubling down on his
innocence and calls the allegations a
political attack anyone Beverly young
Nelson says she was 16 years old when
Roy Moore attacked her after offering
her a ride home from her job as a
waitress putting his hands on my breasts
I tried to open my car door to leave but
he reached over he locked it so I could
not get out she says more parked his car
behind the restaurant where she worked
and I was begging him just stop my dear
is running down my face instead of
stopping he began squeezing my neck
attempting to force my head onto his
crotch at yesterday's press conference
Nelson brought along her high school
yearbook which she says was signed by
Moore I don't even know the woman I
don't know anything about her
but with his wife by his side Moore
remained defiant continued without
hesitation this is absolutely false he
is the most gentle most con man that I
have ever known in my life
Republican leaders are calling on Moore
to step aside right away some suggesting
that Alabama voters right in Luther
strange who lost a primary to Moore
to be best for him the state his family
the GOP and the country he stepped aside
he should not be a United States I hope
that he steps down immediately
if these accusations are true that it be
no place for him in the Senate but more
supporters in deeply read Alabama are
determined to fight Washington's
establishment I believe Swamp quality
the scandal has Republicans scrambling
to figure out how to retain their Senate
Majority and what to do if more were to
win Arizona Republican Senator Jeff
Flake went as far as saying he would
support the Democrat in the race Doug
Jones / Roy Moore Norah
all right man well thank you so much